Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
and the news yeah all right well let me
get to the story and then yeah you can
decide how you feel about the whole
thing
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
is in trouble after photos of Trudeau
surface where he was wearing brown face
and black face it's embarrassing it's
kind of hurt his reputation with some
people anyway I mention this because
Halloween is coming up in a couple of
weeks and seriously thinking about it
millions of Americans are at risk of
making the same mistake as Trudeau so
tonight I asked a friend of the show to
come by to explain which colors are safe
to paint your face this Halloween he's a
star on blackish and his Netflix
stand-up comedy special comes out
October 8th please welcome our good
friend mr. Deon Cole
being here Deon please Conan hey America
listen up the following colors are not
safe to paint your face
this Halloween black brown tan khaki
yellow
hi red olive bronze mocha cafe latte and
caramel Frappuccino and also the Old
Spice guy Thank you Thank You Dion we
know that colors to stay away from now
what are some of the safe colors the
following colors are safe purple you can
wear purple face alright goes a bunch of
grapes a Viking Lakers fan
alright now just don't post the picture
with a black and white filter because
you're gonna bring your ass right back
that's true any other colors blue faces
okay you can go as a smirk or as a
member of the Blue Man Group you gotta
give it up to that Blue Man Group
I tell you three white guys painting
their faces really dark and playing the
drums it's close to races but not racist
good job BMG there's white face now you
know you can go as wide as you wanna go
okay there was a ghost a white Walker or
a Conan
and finally orange it's a good Halloween
color you can go as a pumpkin or a
carrot see or do the same color because
if you paint your face Orange no one can
call you a racist
[Applause]